c'est aussi la déception de se dire que
finalement nos enfants doivent connaître
ça que nos parents ils ne peuvent pas
vieillir calmement que le peuple
craignant qui n'a pas mérité tout ça il
enfin c'est un pays européen qui doit
malheureusement reconnaître à nouveau la
guerre mon père il était resté dans la
ville de tcherny if et qui a été
malheureusement beaucoup touché à 70% de
la Villette détruite et là c'était mon
quotidien beaucoup changé par contre il
y a un an je vivais plus parce que
c'était une peur extrême de ne plus
jamais pouvoir voir ma famille et
surtout que je ne pouvais absolument
rien faire pour